you remember i said
you remember i said
um you need all these definitions okay
the most awkward and clunky of the
definitions i would say personally is
number three i think that's the most
awkward looking one and when i write it
down um people like what
why
why would you
why would you bother with a definition
like this if you can say this or even
this a bit weird i get that you know
this is just like it's like
mathematicians are trying to make it
hard okay
well everyone's different let me show
you the main application of this one
okay
we know how to graph things we know how
to graph lots of things we know how to
graph this we know how to graph this and
all the variations of those we know how
to graph this
now what about
what about things involving this
absolute value now
if you think about this this definition
makes it so simple right because by
definition where i see the absolute
value of x it means
it's equal to x
if x is positive or equal to zero
and it's equal to negative x if x is
negative now this paints a very clear
picture i know what this looks like and
i know what this looks like watch
we'll go from left to right
on the left hand side over here x is
negative
right
so i'm in this category this is the
condition i'm satisfied
so therefore in this region
i'm graphing y equals negative x i've
been graphing that for ages it just
looks like this
for the rest of the domain when x is
positive or equal to zero it looks like
y equals x and i know what that looks
like too
it looks like that
so this bouncy looking character is y
equals the absolute value of x right and
you can see how obviously it matches up
to all the definitions you already know
okay look at this one for instance it's
the positive value of a number okay so
you're like what's the positive value of
negative 3 and the answer is
it's that's terrible aim but you get the
idea it's three
okay you see how all the definitions do
fit together this one makes sense when
you're doing graphical things and the
people who are starting on exercise 3d
um you'll need to consult that